on a une quinzaine de structures locales
quand même qu'ils sont en capacité
d'assurer des dépannages alimentaires
plus ou moins importants selon les
villes et selon les forces en présence
s'il faut continuer à être présent pour
les bénéficiaires
il faut dans la mesure du possible et
puis sans mettre en danger les personnes
non plus puisqu'on a déjà quelques cas
de personnes qui restent chez elles
parce que soit le sont dans une tranche
d'âge un petit peu plus à risque que les
autres soit parce qu'elles craignent
pour leur santé ce qu'on peut comprendre
c'est quand même un petit peu anxiogène
toutes ces affaires là et puis on essaye
de ne pas prendre les choses à la légère
du tout il faut assurer les questions
aussi d'hygiène par exemple conflans
sainte honorine
on a été obligé de fermer puisque les
locaux se nettoie en sous sols
faiblement aéré malgré tout et quand ils
reçoivent le public c'est dans une salle
qui est traitée qu'à mise à disposition
par la mairie et la mairie par sécurité
a fermé tous ses espaces du coup les
amis sont bloqués peuvent pas un peuvent
payer quoi on n'a jamais trop de
bénévoles puisque plus on a de bénévoles
et plus on peut diversifier les missions
donc en fait c'est sûr qu'on va essayer
de maintenir une bonne qualité de
soutien sur l'alimentaire parce que
c'est quand même un axe compliqué à
gérer pour les personnes seules les
personnes en hôtel des familles
monoparentales les personnes qui peuvent
pas trop bouger de chez elles qui sont
déjà handicapées ou fragilisées qu'on
pas forcément de lien familial ou qu'on
pas forcément des bons contacts
pour x raisons avec leur voisinage
difficulté de comprendre la langue et
tout ça et donc du coup on essaye quand
même de maintenir des lieux de vie aussi
ouvert on va dans nos appel à bénévoles
dans nos propositions de missions
demandé aux aux gens qui se propose que
s'ils se sentent en capacité d'apporter
un soutien sur l'aide aux devoirs on les
mettra en lien avec une personne car
l'expérience au secours populaire
on comprendra un contact en premier avec
les la personne qui se proposent pour
s'assurer quand même que c'est une
démarche sérieuse avec une personne qu
un minimum de compétences et tout ça et
après on proposera un une mise en
relation
donc ça ça va me prendre peut-être un
petit peu de temps puisque ça va
nécessiter de démultiplier et ça peut
être gourmande et des vols aussi